Hi, everyone.
In this lesson, we're going to take a look at packed actors
and level instancing, and what that
means when working with Unreal and building your world.
So let's get started.
So you'll see the definitions I have in here in our slides.
We have packed actors.
This tool allows for assets to be calculated,
not multiple times, but once, making it easier for you
to have tons of static meshes,
combining them into a Blueprint type optimized
to render static meshes.
And this is super helpful, especially
if you're managing your world, and you
need to have several things in there that are very
important for your scene.
Say you want a collection of rocks
to be in this very post-apocalyptic world,
or maybe there's junk and there are metal pieces.
So all that is draw calls.
All that takes time.
Even though we're using maybe Nanite,
this will actually help even more further
that cause to be able to make the world seem believable
and be populated with lots of things
that are easily calculated.
So this really does try to relieve
the burden of lots of items in your environment.
So we have a level instancing also.
This allows for heavy management of static meshes
to organize or nest actors to make levels easier to build.
So you can actually add this.
Now, the cool thing about working with this,
you can work this with a minimal, simple environment.
Say you're just using your simple level
and you have sub levels,
or you can use this with world partition.
It's really up to you.
And I'm going to show you a little bit of HLODs too
in the mix within this,
but you can scale in the viewport window
when you do build these out and hit compile
and the asset will update in the level
with all copies in place.
It's best to add these externally
after an empty blueprint is made.
So there's no limitations on transforms and scale options.
This may occur sometimes, but for the most part,
note, you can scale later in the details of the objects
under its hierarchy listings.
This helps when more than one item
in the blueprint for quick access.
So it simply works kind of like you would
with a regular blueprint like I was showing you earlier,
where you can actually go in there
and edit some things after the fact,
but there will be some options to be able
for compiling and so forth.
So let's go and jump into Unreal
and take a look at this stuff up close.
So here in Unreal, you'll see that I have a sample
of a level instancing here.
And then we also have one for a pack level actor.
Now the level instancing shows me
the assets that we have in place here.
They show the small, almost like an overview of it.
So we're not getting the full completed options in here.
You'll actually see the instance level here.
So I can still go into this particular level,
do some editing if I needed to and save it as I go.
So it's kind of straightforward.
It's basically like nesting a level inside your scene,
especially where there's lots of stuff to manage.
But we also over here have a packed level actor
and this pack level actor, you'll notice
it also has a instancing type of a level effect
where it looks like we're having a sub level
that's loaded into our scene
and allows us to go in here and mess with this object.
You'll notice under advances level behavior.
So we can say embedded or standalone.
So more level instance actors and the main world partition
or standalone use level streaming
to load levels instance actors.
So this is what I meant.
You can use this for world partition
or our standard level old school way
of doing things when you have a level
and you have instance levels in place.
So let's go ahead and build one really quick.
I'll show you how it works.
I'm gonna go to my content drawer here
and I'm gonna simply type in rock.
So we're gonna pull up the rock we have.
So we'll get this stylized rock.
I'm gonna pull it into our scene.
I'm gonna move this over
and let me rotate him just a bit
and move him a little bit farther away from things.
And then I'm gonna go ahead and instance him
or basically duplicate him.
Keep my finger on the alt key and move transform this.
And I'm gonna scale him down just a tad
just to make it a little bit different
and then rotate him around.
Now I'm gonna make two of these.
So we'll grab this guy
and we'll hit the W key and also alt
and instance this over
and just move him into the plane for now, that's fine.
So both of these are ready to go in my environment
but now it's up to me to be able to change them.
And maybe I want them to be a bit different
as well as I wanna make it so that
if I have a lot of these
I'm not gonna run into any calculation issues in my scene.
So I'm gonna go in here and grab this particular one
both this pair, I'm gonna right click
and you're going to see under level
we're going to have a create level instance
and create a packed level actor.
So if I create a level instance
it's going to ask me where my pivot's going to be.
It's gonna ask me all these details
and I can simply hit okay.
And I can choose what I want at center
the actor world origin, that's up to me.
And I wanna click that it's external actors here
and always show dialogue that's very important.
So I'm gonna hit okay with that.
So I hit okay, it tells me where to put it
so that it can stream it automatically.
I'm not loading it up in here
like typically we do in the old school way
we're loading in here so it's based on asset
on a more finite level if I wanted to.
Now, looking at the other way to do it
I'm gonna hit okay, that's all right
I'm not really building you.
And we're gonna go and grab the other one here
and I'm going to shift select these, right click
go to level and we're gonna say
create a packed level actor.
Now the packed level actor you'll notice
this is the packed level actor interface.
And we go over here to this one
and we go ahead and do level
and do create level instance.
The interfaces are quite the same.
Like there's not a whole huge difference between them.
And that may be confusing for some
they kind of do the same job.
Think of it this way
because the packed level actor in here
if I hit okay is also going to ask me to build out
or save a level to be able to reference.
Now, if we look at the ones that's okay
if it's already asking me this unreal being very
very sterling, very consistent there
which I really appreciate.
If you go in here
and we look at the ones that I've already made
you'll see those assets in place in a ghosted form.
It'll show me all these merged pipes
that are underneath this level instancing.
If we go to this one here under packed level actors
you'll notice we can edit here.
There's no actual active edit within this one.
If I have to go into this level itself
but over here, I can go to the pack level actor
and edit that blueprint pack actor.
And this is what I meant in my notes
where you actually, it acts like a blueprint in our scene
where we go into the viewport
and then we can now see the rocks that we have in place
and then we can choose
and edit them according to what we need
which is actually pretty cool.
This allows us to be able to do so.
So hopefully you found this enlightening
and what he can do
but let's actually cover one more thing.
That's not necessarily my slides
that is covered in other classes
but I want to show you a little bit
of a difference between, or I should say
the tools that you have to manage the overhead.
Now, if I have these packed level actors
and level instancing
and I'm managing lots of assets in my scene
you can also use a tool called an HLOD.
Now, HLODs, if you go in here
I can pull up the hierarchical LOD outliner.
These HLODs allow us to be able to grab certain items.
I can generate a level of detail
or almost like a priority in a way
of managing draw calls within this system.
Now we can generate clusters for the whole level
and we can do that underneath the world settings
if we wanted to.
And we can go down to where the HLODs live
a quick way to get there is simply just type it in
or just scroll and you'll see the HLOD system here.
You'll notice it says HLOD setup assistant
and we can make it so there's a setup in here
ready to go and loads a generic kind of set up for it.
We can also make a single cluster
for the whole level if you wanted to.
And you'll see there's an HLOD baking system
kind of gives you a little bit of
just a little bit extra
if you wanted to position things
but we're not gonna worry about that.
So I can go now into here
and generate a cluster for the whole world
if I wanted to, or I can base it based on
and eliminating once I build it
things that I want or don't want for this scene.
So if I generate this, it's gonna generate
and now it shows me all these in here
and it says they've changed
so I have to generate my proxy.
So I can choose like, hey, you know what?
I want these to be in this HLOD
and maybe I don't want these to be in.
So I can delete a cluster set if I needed to.
So that's actually pretty great.
So again, the HLOD allows us to load things
according to what we need
and it makes it so things are a bit more compact
and the draw calls are managed via this cluster system.
So there are not using too much memory
with lots of items in our scene.
We can also create a priority box
and this is pretty cool.
We can go into here and type in HLOD in here
and let's go to volumes here
and we'll go to the hierarchy volume.
HLOD may not pop up automatically
but we'll go to this guy here
and then we'll click on that.
Now this volume is a priority box.
You can say, hey, I want to get these pieces of geometry
like say we haven't converted these guys yet.
So I want to make it so these guys are drawn
as if they are one cluster group
and this can help again with the draw calls.
So I've now made a priority box.
That is my HLOD box and Unreal is going to use this
to help manage things, the overhead and make it cleaner
and make it easier to process elements in our scene.
That's it with this video.
In the next video, we're going to dive deeper
into building our world and some of the assets
and tools that we have at our disposal.
Thanks again.